hi guys Cheers welcome to Friday hurry
it feels almost like long to be doing it
out of this this has been one of the
craziest weeks of my life baby or just
as of recently and I honestly don't even
remember what happened let's just start
with this hi I just got done something a
segment for the Pete Holmes show that
will go up later in the month of
February they won't let me film anything
in there but it was super fun and now
I'm headed over to mamrie's place to do
the camp Takota livestream
see you there but I found this goes up I
will largely see you there
what about this right now you guys are
in friend diary except it's mostly us
but it is high it is good good wait
isn't right diary today yeah but this is
next week bye diary you met all go to
power fiction I am look at the creatures
and is so tired
oh oh right this thing birthdays
yourself we're going to bed again
Jocelin am a jealous doing a stand-up
comedy show I'm a marine are going to
Brittany Joseph couldn't try and come to
Brittany but doesn't work out we're
going to meet up after and try and dance
but you guys are coming with us and it's
gonna be really fun time I have feelings
I'm gonna get drunk and fall down that's
my prediction
I'll put money on it oh this thing we've
made a pit stop and we don't know where
our driver is he's in the most hilarious
band of all time
and I wish I could film so much more of
it but he wanted to run lines with those
laughing that's what um company we're
working for wait nope didn't need money
so much video what studio and when he
found out that we're all going to Vegas
I guess uber drivers don't know that you
booked a Vegas thing until then we would
like at it yeah sometimes I get paid way
more and he gets a free night in Vegas
he started calling all this fray cold
all day here comes just coming back now
it's gonna be years we left the car amok
with all our [ __ ] I mean that's said we
just bought a bunch of beer and coconut
water and a shot
yeah alright I'm about a lighter that
shocks you
which is really great we're making
really great choices and purchases a
nurse I don't I'm like yeah yeah just
this key to the bathroom
also hate to back my car was completely
uh not and all of our laptops up in the
trunk I like literally everything I own
that is important to me was in the
school and then we just call him up I
got him out on it before then that we
are getting gas because we ran out of
gas I get again and this is like it's
common night it's a comedy of errors
happening right now we literally just
left the gas station and then you took a
phone call with his boss cuz his gas
light came on like I need to know what
to do and we're like 60 to 70 miles
outside of Vegas our way this is a
longer trip today
so he told us that he was asking us if
we should stop or if we should go ahead
and another option option like hey sirs
should we stop for just run out of gas
and get on the highway and get murdered
I had to say I want to see Brittany not
Kyle watch out this we got into the room
and it's a beautiful girl Viva Las Vegas
baby
oh we have a balcony here's another
thing now we're going to Brittany
mamrie is representing another classic
music act on her person what I do always
was like heart you're really just gonna
be yeah happy birthday
and then this guy what happens in Vegas
gets British prisoner
okay
I quit this thing happened next it's the
morning after her
I mean hey I'm decided memory I decided
we twins today
Johnson cleated yourself up
I needed frozen blueberries out of my
sweet potato fries returned last night
Mary night came up here and ate all of
us amount of room service food and
literally have been talking about eating
it for hours just before it kicked up
here and then we decided is that it
would be smart for us to push the cart
of all the food in front of a different
hotel room door no one knew it was us
and then never hit the fry detector get
this oh yeah I want money and money and
also look who's giving us a ride back
here Los Angeles give our sweet precious
Gabriel we don't know where he is right
now
tucked in I am doing tech but we found
saviours in God so conveniently going
back to Los Angeles the day that we're
going back to Los Angeles and like we
said poor sweet Gabriel who didn't know
how to pump the gas and you wherever you
are right now Gabriel just please
subscribe to my channel then the local
morning today Hannah Hart made me hurt
myself are gonna take over YouTube
nation I was supposed to be there 10
minutes ago and then still 9 miles away
and I'm in
yeah youtubenation I do not disrespect
your shell I'm sorry I just overslept
this morning and then this we just did
youtubenation boilers boilers boilers
boilers
oh that's legal no that's like nope
can't show that
hello it's now this day I know where I
am in time track of these vlogs but
tonight is our camp Takota
premiere party we've invited like a
whole bunch of youtubers and friends all
sorts of people and it's gonna be
outside Scooby super Sun I just left a
meeting a lunch meeting where I think I
over caffeinated and I might have eaten
too much cheese I took a risk and I'm
trying to get home as fast as possible
battle moments stomach and person are
about to do and I'm all the way on the
other side of town
why are we stopping because this trip
needs to turn okay ah well there you go
what a crazy week today's the day that
camp Takota comes out and I will be on
my social media like
see I gotta go I gotta get back to
Twitter even though I'm shooting this a
day before comes back so I'm creating a
false illusion that doesn't exist I'm
not really wearing pigtails sometimes I
just want to undo my hair let it dry
like this I just feel like I need to
explain that all the people out there
that are like she's trying very hard to
hummingbirds just taste each other they
were here for the pigtails
No